ugandan president yoweri museveni
welcoming frank-walter Steinmeier to
kampala the german foreign minister's
visit comes at just the right time from
07 e at the age of 71 he's running for
re-election again he's been president
for 29 years that's longer than most
Ugandan s have been alive every year
forty thousand young people graduate
from university and then struggled to
find work they have to offer more
opportunities for my young people's
what's happening these days they young
people leave campus but you come out and
graduate you walk on the streets and you
don't get jobs yesterday so human rights
in Uganda is in total quagmire because
as a lot of a collection violence I a
measurement of public funds and collapse
and the correction is a not free and
fair they want votes after voting them
they go and they make themselves
developed and they leave us alone
Steinmeier is scheduled to meet with two
of the leading opposition candidates to
give his visit at least the appearance
of non-partisanship